thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where today we have Jason
Channing with us
okay
thank you guys so much
is there anything you particularly
yourself would like to talk about
it did sound like a setup huh I think
James is like what the [__] are you
trying to do there's no shut up but if
if not then we can go for something that
the fans uh recommended okay let's do
that
in that case uh fans in our Discord
which if you're part of the Discord you
get to ask questions and we will answer
them so join the Discord by joining
patreon join the patreon uh the fans
would like to know
are you making it up no I'm not okay how
would you dispose of a body
if you had to do it oh dude oh go ahead
Jason okay I would cut the fingers wow
um three of them on each hand because
five of them is a lot
and then I will cut
um I I would take the head because it's
really heavy and then I would uh torso I
would do it in uh four pieces
yeah and then I'll freeze them okay
yeah yeah thank you and then I air tight
airtight freeze four pieces in the thing
and then leg
ah so two pieces like a crab yeah huh
like a piece
I go ah yeah break them it's got
stronger
it probably won't break but a couple
times
what are you going to do with all that I
want to tell you something impressed so
I'm gonna take uh I will go to uh
Hermosa beach oh yeah
and then I have six
and I have six fingers and that feeds
them to the seagulls yeah they'll eat it
they'll take it to the house or whatever
the thing is they'll scatter it yeah
they'll scatter it okay and then I take
one piece of the Torso I put in a
backpack and then I go on the ferry to
Catalina Island and I go oops
we just bought it and they go what is
that I go oh my my bread yeah but then
but one of the person will be like but
what is that
an alcohol I don't know it was a heavy
bread yeah I didn't use that machines
this time yeah
fermented sour and um and then I maybe
cook some oh yeah I was just copying
Japanese
did some good work no that's not good
work but but then I'll take those and
maybe I dispose it in the trash can just
in the trash yeah because you you can't
I I'm just too tired I don't want to
take it on the ferry all the time yeah
so I just expensive the fairy tick it's
expensive and then uh so I put one there
and
um I put one I put one I'll go to my
friend's house and I go Hey where's your
garbage can
foreign
's place okay how come just throw it
into because I feel like people will
probably be like oh she would never have
uh but my place is too clean though
that's what I'm saying
apparent that there's something in there
no no it's just like a finger but you
know oh okay
it would make sense at her place if you
drop a dead body over her face no no not
a dead body just like a thigh
you take out your trash no yeah my place
is like
spotless spotless now so you take it out
that day now are you telling her that
you're doing it or are you not telling
her and just hoping that she no I'm
gonna tell her and then what would you
say I'll go hey Colleen I just I was
like yeah sure no problem come on over
wow good you know no no you chose right
no but I go but I go um I have this like
really big piece of pork meat because I
cook it and then I go um so you season
it with everything how would you cook it
and I would say I'm sorry my My Religion
doesn't allow pork in my house you know
Pork yeah I'm just kidding is lamb
[Laughter]
but you think that will work I think
that will work I think you're off to
okay I'll be careful yeah I think that's
it okay start stop picking up the phone
I'm not available
your plan sucks
what happens to the Head ultimately
the head I I have to freeze it and then
uh think about it for a couple days
[Laughter]
I would do it maybe maybe
um
how would you freeze it would you freeze
it where if you open the freezer it's
staring at you still every day oh no no
no no no no I put it behind the ice
cream
[Laughter]
ice cream
I've been staying there for years yeah
just in case people open all right now
you have to think about this you have to
get your Alibi straight yeah so which
one of us are you going to use to help
build your Alibi so that we say oh he
was with me the whole time this is what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna be like hey guys
can I please come to do JK news and then
after we do JK news I'll be like hey
guys can you guys please help me
everybody pitch in a little bit
brainstorm some ideas
a little bit a writer's room
but one camera on One camera on just so
I could review the tape yeah yeah yeah
in case you forget
cause you're not going to write it down
some good ideas yeah why would you write
it down yeah because it's evidence
evidence
so for instance we could do a thing
where on the day of the murder yeah we
could say no we were at JK filming right
guys we were filming a video about how
he would hide a body is that me pitching
in a little bit if we say yes what is
that me pitching in a little bit if I
say yes yeah of course okay
is the thing yeah who's the person
you're gonna kill if you got a pick
um one of us is the body no no not not
us not us is there someone that you
would want to murder yeah like a
competing comedian or something that
gets in your way yeah
um Irani Chang or something
because he's killing it dude we got to
get rid of kill Bobby Lee Bobby Lee okay
no I'm just kidding because he was here
uh who who would I kill I don't know I
don't I don't I don't want to kill
anybody okay not even Peng
um kill maybe like uh
like a
like Katie to Tara
maybe kill the guy that uh was in
Starbucks and then he was reading the
menu
too long yeah yeah because it's like
know your order yeah yeah the line's
long you have 15 minutes to figure out
and he's a potato so we yeah so he's got
to go all right let's say out of all of
us in this scenario somebody betrayed
you and ratted you out who do you think
did it
um
I what who's most likely I think Colleen
I mean I don't know who Colleen is no
but after that response no who's Colleen
you trusted her Colleen sorry oh that's
me
what do you think happened there why
would she be the one I think Colleen did
it too
yeah I think she's for sure Colleen
would clean water
do you think you have a lot of Justice
in your heart yeah
checks out
yes but I wouldn't take her for disloyal
to the friends oh oh no but because
she's friends with you thank you okay
yeah the guilt and then okay also
um would you kill somebody
huh
I'm kidding I'm sorry
do I strike you as a person who has a
lot of Justice in my heart but would
kill somebody I don't know I just asked
two different questions so then
to let things die down a little bit
where do you hide
I hide
um at the best place ever my own
apartment
[Laughter]
why is that the best place ever no but
why do you assume that they're gonna
come and ask the thing why do you assume
that they're gonna come ask me maybe
because the time would I get caught
though Starbucks had a nest cam or [__]
let's say the last scene the last time
scene of this guy was at Starbucks and
it was him looking at the menu and then
it was you behind him going [__]
yeah and that's why they are they're
they're your number one suspect number
one suspect
and then
and then hey you know I'm just running
down this list of suspects and I just
need to know because you're the cops
I just need to make sure that uh you
know everything's on the up and up yeah
this could probably have nothing to do
with you but where were you on the day
that this guy was murdered I killed the
guy
yourself to be a rat I'm sorry I
apologize I've been wanting to tell
somebody for so long
for six hours
[Laughter]
six hours of my life
okay okay do it again
[Laughter]
somebody he goes to a random person at
the store and he goes I just killed
somebody and they go what he goes
nothing
I just had to tell somebody I have to
say it oh I feel so much better
that was awesome
so much better I go I say it and I go
that's so nice
but for me thank you for listening
I think the body is really
really tough yeah what is that is that
difficult but isn't that the best way
[__] body holy [__] but how would you
how would you do it how would you do the
thing Ryan's good let's start with Joe
okay me yeah because I feel like you
thought about it the most
geez depends on where the killing
happened okay it happened here in the
office in this office oh we have plenty
of time is there
is there blood stain yeah it's right
there yeah there's blood stain
oh okay so you got to get rid of body
and carpet yeah yeah so rip out the
carpet
uh
uh throw the body in a trunk and then
well that's good because can is really
light
it's nominated yeah
yeah and where does the body go from
there
there's a lot of nature
or all around La
is that where you would go but no but
then they're gonna smell it the dogs the
dogs yeah they're nice dogs the police
dogs yeah or the hiking dogs ocean you
can go but I mean if you didn't want I
mean the easiest thing to do which is
probably the most disgusting is you're
gonna have to eat something no chop it
all up and throw it and flush it down a
toilet
it is the most disgusting I don't know
if you can because just the bone is so
hard like I feel like people say chop it
up but like have you seen how cows are
should I say three fingers they need
after the three figures he's like I'm
exhausted that was so hard get through
bone like it's so messy you need some
DeWalt stuff I don't know like you have
to cut through all that the easiest
thing is just to like load it up drive
somewhere pretty far dump it and then be
gone and then but then if you dump it
they're gonna find the whole thing
how
they all find it most of the time they
all they all find it but yeah most of
the time sometimes
there's deserts here there's oceans
there's I don't know really well I mean
if I could cut through like I guess I
will cut it that'd be the smart that
would be the best but that means we're
gonna have to get a lot of tools like by
yourself and if you have do you have
unlimited time you're just gonna be
sitting here sawing away every day when
you're like I'm so tired you go to
Burger King and you eat your lunch break
you come back you saw again yeah you
know
power tools Home Depot yeah so then all
of your neighbors can hear you going
fine that's that's one of the common
mistakes all over the place too the
smell to over a period of time yeah
worse okay I don't want to break it back
you're like an emergent blender and just
try to turn it into grassy but I mean
you're like trying to flush it well
they're like this big
I just bought one like one use but after
a certain part with the immersion
blender like you're like this is not
cutting anything and then once you hit
that sweet spot it cuts right through
you're like oh sweet what you said
Breaking Bad to the bad version so
you're talking about chemically melting
it down I think yeah but that's the
problem is buying the chemicals yeah but
it smells who knows that's the heart
because everything's not like you have a
paper trail now yeah there's a paper
trail those are controlled substances
too right acids at that level but you
can pay cash no that's why it is good to
have some cash actually you might be
able to like yeah Ling long Trading
Company or something
I think that's your preferred method
though no I think that was just one way
to get around the whole like chopping up
the the body because that would be like
difficult I think you would have to
it's either you chop it up you have to
chop it up I think if you want to clean
getaway yeah and you gotta chop it up
and then you get some pigs dude you find
some pigs
starve the Pig I mean we do have a lot
of knives and stuff here so you don't
have to go to Home Depot that's true but
that will take so long though that
exactly but then you shouldn't have
killed the guy but you killed the guy so
you have to do it you have to you have
to take the time yep if you want to get
away with it then you have to chop up a
body
oh why chop up the body like that's all
I'm saying like wrap them up
bag
but if you had like a like a high a high
resource like you had a A Private Pilot
who had his own plane you're able to
drive it to that and then take the plane
with the body and then dump it in like a
[__] like jungle or something and
then just in a different country
international waters yeah some yeah and
then I you have to be like well
connected with resources to be able to
like find a way to hide it not if you
have pigs
yeah let's go back
so you go to Farmer John and then just
be like hey hey I got some pig food for
you what if you get a boat and you do
the same thing but with like maybe you
throw some Chum in the water you go to
some areas where you might find some
sharks or something you throw some Chum
in the water but then people's gonna be
like whoa what is that big piece
the hardest part about getting it but
why you so nosy man
even though the boat and the plane are
totally amazing the hard part is between
here and the boat in the plane
especially the driving there's so many
ways that people go I remember that guy
with the ears he was pulling a big ass
suitcase
I think I'll never forget a guy when he
was like that yeah
we have to go in nature so like if it
happened here and it was me I would
probably get a wrap like first wrap them
up in like some tarp or plastic bags so
it's not leaking yeah and then I'll Open
this gate and then back my truck in and
then load them in while the truck is
while the bottom while my truck is
inside the office so no one ever sees me
carry anything anywhere then I'll
probably go somewhere hella far and then
uh dig probably like a a hole that's big
enough to
um fit all these desks and then I'll put
them in there and then I'll light it on
fire so that if there's a big fire the
fire is below the ground so you don't
see a giant
um what is it called Smoke yeah and like
bonfire they end up being camping
equipment so just
and then what's left of the bones
probably have to use a sledgehammer to
powderize it and then from there figure
out how to get rid of that or mix it
with concrete it's like a two-day thing
you have to you have to dude you have to
yeah oh okay concrete yeah currently it
makes it concrete and then like [__]
pave them somewhere
there's a school I bring them back here
and now that wall is covered in new
tiles but the behind the tile is the
person so it's like an extra 10 inches
[Laughter]
you always pick can size because like
think about how much easier it would be
to move his body but what if can't the
can cement only covers half of the wall
dude I got an easy I gotta wait either
way all right you open up that couch you
put the body in yeah
and then you say free couch on offer
it's not just [__] free pick it up
today no questions asked yeah yeah did
they take the couch goodbye alert
there's a body in there there's a body
in here
how to get in there I just got this
couch from somebody else the other day
and that's what you say you blame it on
somebody else if we post this video do
we get flagged for talking about a dead
body no it's Jason Chinese
this should be fine right yeah I think
it's okay
if you that's a really good idea Bart
it's so good it sounds like you've done
it before yeah private property is a
great place to hide a body but as long
as that site is not where people are
going to come looking for them yeah sure
yeah but people was going to be like why
is Bart doing cement all the time just
one time yeah oh he's a brick player now
that's why before the murder you have to
be seen doing cements yeah yeah yeah
yeah they do it as usual thing it's a
side gig it's a side hustle
get the powder bake them into cookies
and stuff and oh God in South Dakota why
bring it back
I mean you're in the desert just bury it
you're done yeah yeah what if you make
homies with
with the at the uh incinerator I mean
the but there's more witnesses yeah
you'd have that have to be a
pre-existing plug you could blackmail
you dude yeah how deep do you have to
dig the hole in the desert or the the
um Forest
so it's a burn you yeah I'd probably
just like four to six feet oh that's not
them that's it huh okay I mean digging a
hole like that by yourself it takes a
while it takes a while yeah I think how
long do you think the the part that's
like dangerous though is um
you don't know who sees you going in
there
you're like oh that's a hard part green
truck driving or that blue tire marks
and [__] yeah he's digging a whole half
a day you got to be careful and burning
I would say get that couch
take it to the harbor
go on a fishing trip okay but who's
taking the couch with you because you're
not gonna move the couch alone
ask on offer up after this
who wants to help me move the couch
yeah put the couch on the boat do some
fishing and then when you catch a tuna
oh I got a tuna and then you kick the
couch over oh no
oh I got a daughter
wear a couch over there an Irish
Japanese guys a really good fisherman
you actually hope Ken and then he comes
up
he's like what the [__] [__]
foreign
[Music]